Buenos días, aquí soy Steve Kauffman y en
mi canal se habla del aprendizaje de
idiomas. Eh si te gusta mi canal, por favor
suscríbete y haz clic sobre la campana para
recibir noticias, bueno. Hoy quiero hablar
de los problemas, tres problemas eh… para
aquellos que quieren aprender idiomas,
problemas que yo siempre veo en los casos
de… de gente que quiere, verdaderamente
quieren aprender idiomas pero,pero  hay es,
es, esos problemas, primera problema es
que no se dan cuenta del tiempo necesario
para aprender, eh… cuando empezamos en
un idioma muchas veces hay un progreso
bastante rápido al principio, que no
sabíamos nada y pues podemos decir alguna
cosa, entendemos algo y este da una
sensación de bueno, de éxito, ¿no? pero
después de un rato se da cuenta de que hay
mucho que ya no podemos decir que no…
palabras que nos hacen, hacen falta ¿no?
Es este, es, es un progreso, es un proceso
digamos, muy lento, este de aprender un
idioma de llegar a un nivel alcanzar a un
nivel que se entiende no sino todo, pero mucho
que podemos tener conversaciones con muchos
amigos en el idioma que estamos
aprendiendo, eh… pero para alcanzar a este
nivel necesitamos muchas palabras, es una
cuestión de mucho tiempo y la gente que no
se dan cuenta de que necesitamos mucho
tiempo para aprender un idioma, bueno se
se frustra ¿no? muchas veces abandonan,
y por eso yo creo que tenemos que, que, que
darse cuenta ¿no? Hay de que darse cuenta
de que es un proceso lento y por eso
necesitamos buscar maneras de gozar de este
proceso, del aprendizaje de idiomas y yo
voy a hablar un poco más sobre este tema,
segunda problema, segundo problema, es que
muchas veces porque no, damos cuenta de que
necesitamos mucho tiempo, si estamos
escuchando, leyendo, porque para mí, el
aprendizaje de idiomas empieza con la
escucha y la lectura, porque no se puede
solamente hablar, hablar, hablar, sin un
vocabulario bastante para poder entender lo
que dice el otro ¿no? entonces es, este
aprendizaje, es basado sobre la escucha
y la lectura, muchas veces cuando estamos
escuchando, leyendo algo pues, tenemos está
sensación que no estamos progresando y qué
bueno vamos a hacer otra cosa y es muy
importante que el tiempo que, que dedicamos
al aprendizaje que sea… 10 minutos, 30
minutos, una hora, dos horas, no importa,
es que tenemos que pensar que este tiempo
es importante, está contribuyendo al
aprendizaje, qué poco a poco escuchando,
leyendo, nuestro cerebro va a acostumbrarse
al nuevo idioma y tenemos que continuar y,
y… es muy fácil pensar otra cosa, jugar, eh
… yo no sé, mirar lo que está aconteciendo
en el Twitter o lo que sea, no, hay que
enfocarse y continuar y estar seguro que el
tiempo que estamos dedicando al aprendizaje
vale la pena, este es la actividad que
ahora, ahora mismo, yo quiero hacer,
entonces está falta de concentración, de
confianza en el proceso mismo de
aprendizaje me parece que es un gran
problema, tercera problema, tercero
problema, siempre para mí que no soy nativo
de español, voy a hacer errores, por
ejemplo, problema en español es masculino
¿no? un problema, pero muchas palabras en
español que terminen con el “a” son
femenino, femenina, femenino, yo no sé pero
para mí hablar con errores, no es un gran
problema, prefiero hablar sin errores o con
la menor cantidad posible de errores, pero
inevitablemente yo voy cometer errores,
pero si yo tendría la posibilidad de hablar
más, porque ahora no, casi nunca ni leo ni
escucho nada en español ni hablo español,
pero si tenía la ocasión de hacerlo más
pues poco a poco, haré menos, menos
errores pero muchas personas tienen
miedo de hacer cometer errores ese es un
gran problema porque, claro que no queremos
cometer errores pero tenemos que cometer
errores, es un contradicción, contradicción
quiero hablar sin errores, pero si yo no eh
cometo errores, es que yo no estoy, yo no
estoy hablando, yo no estoy tratando de
mejorarme, entonces el hecho de hacer errores
es importante y no es porque hay una
corrección o alguien te dice no este, no
no es correcto tienes que decir otra cosa,
no te va a corregir enseguida, no, es un
proceso lento como todo en el aprendizaje
de idiomas es un proceso para que el
que el cerebro poco a poco se acostumbra
al nuevo idioma y, pero no tenemos que
que tener miedo de los errores, los errores son un,
eh, parte inevitable y necesario en el proceso
de aprendimiento, de aprendizaje,
aprendimiento es italiano, aprendizaje de
idiomas, entonces todo eso se puede resumir
en un concepto es que tenemos que gozar del
de aprendizaje, que necesitamos tiempo,
que tenemos que enfocarse, concentrarse y
que tenemos que hacer errores y todo eso
debe ser agradable si podemos aprender de
una manera agradable seguro que vamos,
seguro que vamos a progresar, aún si muchas
veces no teníamos la impresión de
progresar, pero con el tiempo, seguro que
estamos progresando, bueno, mucho
gusto y disculca discúlpame
por los errores en mi español.
Adiós, hasta luego.